citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to watch the Justice League fight the
Teen Titans if you want to see an entire
league beat up some kids you're in the
right place very excited to watch this
with John who as per tradition also
hasn't seen it that's true I'm holding
strong koi I haven't broken yet you're
secretly watching these like right
before
Justice League very very big villains of
the Titans right man uh speaking of
villainy we will be at WonderCon
probably this Sunday because it is
actually the Sunday this Sunday
you won't see us next Sunday no no I
don't see anybody next Sunday Sunday the
26th at 11 A.M you'll see us and Greg
who will be there talking about the
state of Marvel the state of DC the
state of the industry and we want some
fan interactivity so be there for more
Rhymes uh also please do like and
subscribe on this video before you go to
WonderCon leave a comment let us know
which of these videos you've enjoyed
which ones you want us to watch next
when you want us to get to the ranking
that's inevitably Gonna Come What do we
do because there's a lot of these most
of all I'd like to think
oh this G fuel is the boys and not only
is it the boys but it's actually
compound V so uh
you're gonna be sprouting powers
oh and if you would like compound VG
fuel or any of the G fuels Link in the
box below get a little description box
you can click your link there and then
you can have the focus of Solomon the
wisdom of all the things that I forgot
from that movie that I enjoyed more than
most and the promo code reject nation is
it reject Nation reject Nation there it
is that's all the data you need if
you're a super sexy reject and you've
earned patreon you get front to back
whole way through without pause resting
faces
but
without further ado
let's fight some Titans
already better music than a lot of Pop
right now oh was that Raven I don't know
she is a Teen Titan reporting live from
the site of a massive battle between the
Justice League and a group of what can
only be described as super villains
calling themselves the Legion of Doom
sounds like sounds like super villains
at the unveiling of their new
headquarters stepped by many on social
media as the Hall of Justice that's who
they bought back black suit Superman oh
yeah it's Gotta Stay okay oh so we're
definitely back in continuity because
these outfits
hey Kristen wig
s
[Music]
hard to fight that ever seen Barry do
the arms yeah that's great I've seen in
the comics I didn't I haven't seen it in
movie is this any way to treat your
guest Superman seeing as how you crash
the party I'd consider us even
[Music]
come on Diana
what happened this guy
cyborg yeah you're gonna take that from
a drone
my man born on a man
made him say smash like the Hulk
just watches
oh
Robin report how's crowd control
[Laughter]
addicted they respond like contemptible
sheep oh man that's who I I like Damien
the crisis I do too like people don't
but I like them
oh
[Laughter]
I'm simply an innocent industrialist
caught in the middle I'll bet
all those innocent industrialists wow
that Old Chestnut
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's go be so cool man I'm sitting
there The Flash movie like uh here they
are like I'm so excited to see stuff
like this no Tom Cruise loves it it's
good I mean it's gonna be a perfect film
yeah top gun Maverick of the year
not in the face
whatever you say
Jesus
that's your new uniform right there I
like it
[Music]
do you know how hard it is to find a
replacement power glove in this day and
age
nice use of face
running from The Flash
whoa
[Music]
come on Wizard don't make me hit you
with
you again
whoa jeez the hour of his Rising is at
hand
I've got this
probably for the best
speaking of the child
oh no oh
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
he's not using any Tech it's magic I
mean any Tech is sufficiently Advanced
as indistinguishable for magic so don't
tell that to Superman because then he's
immune to not just Tech
oh man
get them to safety I'll keep him
distracted comment cover
s
[Music]
sometimes gotta spanking out of the car
oh
no I'm being underutilized
no you're worth boy
Target locked Damien Stand Down
late now
get up there bats
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the end of Dark Knight Rises but a
little different retconned
it's a lot of dead fish I know the the
atlanteans are going to be pissed again
damn looks like an anime creature yeah
it did what we have is an empty shell
with no answers if you had followed
orders and done what you're told we'd
know more come on cut him some slack at
least he was trying to
foreign
not that I disagree
it's about teamwork all I see is a lot
of ineffectual grandstanding which is
why I prefer to work alone and my dad
thinks I'm difficult
have you ever considered boarding school
peanut gallery well the baby just makes
everyone uncomfortable like everyone's
just like oh why it's Batman you're
you're really gonna step to me right now
um Batman
thank you
stunt you pulled hey every time we're
gonna lose it when he comes to live
action because I get excited every time
he's the MVP of all of these truly
teammates are a liability then what am I
to you an unavoidable irritation sure
a rash
oh Teen Titans are coming back big in
the comics right now and it's really
exciting through a Nightwing comic ooh
Now's the Time hop on people maybe I'll
start reading something the Nightwing
run is I think the best Nightwing's ever
been right now ever
Danger Room sequence activate
VR Missions
you were having a nightmare last night I
was just wondering if everything's look
I appreciate your concern I guess but
they're Dreams Just streams glad that's
over
you know you're naked right huh
[Music]
so what
animals are naked I'm the entire Animal
Kingdom crammed into a single
magnificent specimen
or something
oh it was just laughing at you
well but out bug
I'll talk to Blue Beetle that way in
maybe few Jaime's spine but
it's not exactly under
a burn
it's Blue Beetle July I thought so but I
don't know now has it moved again
Justice for solo I think sholo's blue
beetles like DC's next big like needs to
make a statement Nightwing Starfire it's
been a while
Nightwing MVP
the new Robin
Welcome Damien
I'll be in my room
would you like to I think I can manage
that is boarding school
more like
sad
oh
stand him you are also born in the
darkness just you and me no Men in
Tights that sounds nice by the way I
bought some new glasses
you might not recognize me
you both won't recognize each other
mysterious Duo of the spectacled folk I
would so love that they try to go on a
day they completely miss each other
enjoying these horror movie flourishing
Frank you're screwing with the wrong guy
he's got a point yeah like the James Wan
elements of uh the live action movies
yeah
assistant
oh it's good good good
he hasn't stopped for an hour and a half
great cardio
time to let others have turn
I'm not
gonna stop until the machine literally
cannot produce any more in pieces
whoa I am the leader of this group as I
see it you're an alien with nowhere else
to go everyone needs a home Damien you
included thank you for chiming in which
girl
I'm here to help you realize your
potential you've been here long enough
when do you think you'll realize yours
ouch dude dude you need to show some
respect
a second I thought he was gonna say you
need to shut up
deservedly
yeah let's go
training stop this
now this is how they'll learn to respect
one another through the sword
[Applause]
that's the difference between you and me
you wear a weapon
I am a weapon that's a bar
oh
just cook Robin yep
is he dead
[Music]
he's still alive oh barely oh this is
going to be an awkward call to Batman
yeah
turn your son into freaking two phase
[Music]
oh Raven healed you we have to tend to
her
sorry
I cooked your freaking head you're half
Freddy Krueger you're better now yeah I
thought you might be hungry
no thanks learn from the turtles and he
folds it in half that's oh man Batman
does he gotta earn it though absolutely
after a team up not before
what is that a shadow no the sun
direction is wrong and look here it's
disconnected from the surface
it's mimicking a shadow
it's wandering like it's looking for
something or someone
there's where where the wizard ran into
it more like stepped in it oh
see teamwork
good detective work the female leads
seem to only be present in order to be
rescued by the leading man but all in
all I find myself reasonably diverted
averted
oh
I've got a lot on my mind right now you
can always share your burdens with me
Clark
stay away from me
dude put your glasses back on someone's
gonna notice you run around the street
Superman
T14 or team or any meanings that's where
the team lives mother Spirit of another
realm protect my brothers and sister
and give me strength to face the dark
force I fear is coming I like her music
yeah it's a Vibe I suppose I should
thank you for healing me
um you're welcome
[Music]
I was groomed for a higher calling my
grandfather I know all about your
grandfather I felt him he was a demon
he was a great man we were going to make
the world stronger I know all about that
game too I don't mean to be rude but
would you mind getting the hell away
from me
okay
I like them together I could see things
about you too it looked like a man but
something more you have other things to
fix here just stay away from me
well you know the secret though he's bad
at thank you
he is perhaps it was a mistake to
challenge you this morning without
knowing the full capacity of your alien
attachment
it won't happen again
this
meeting did he just say he's sorry
it probably has respect for you now that
you you know
that's the way you earn it with them I
mean In fairness
oh no
oh
damn oh this is so cool this is not what
I was expecting at all this movie
this is how you humanize Superman sure
dark magic
this is how you get an injustice gods
amongst us it's coming
Atomic Skull I've got
a lot stronger
that's not good you don't look so good
jeez
it's the Snyder cut yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Batman knows absolutely he's barely
alive Clark what's wrong with you
oh
the rising is coming
you cannot stop it
oh you have your part to play the good
will be
girl
why did you say that day
my mother's name was Raven Martha with
any luck military satellites are
tracking him now and what will we do
wait for him to pull the moon from the
sky but will they do there's military
he hasn't said anything about doing
something like that has he
you tell me if he did right because that
sounds dangerous get back to that island
of yours and lock yourself in the
darkest deepest tomb you can find you
can't expect me to hide
was worth a shot
I like the part of this teamwork is
knowing when your partners are not gonna
go with your plans
tactical just kind of accepting that but
try yeah we didn't know anything about
Raven when we took her in except that
she needed a home I was taught that
knowledge was power and nothing about
her you have to have a little faith
sometimes faith is belief based on an
absence of data it invites disaster
I would love to see Damon Damon Damon
Christmas party
you have no idea how frustrating it is
he reminds me of my sister
training to kill
Shameless detail Shameless they took
time to animate them oh and like frame
by Shameless
field room looks great
that's what we need what
[Laughter]
that's who I was thinking at the time
and stinking with you uh you know and
then now she's got a solution
oh boy
now are your search results of Superman
sightings and to recent Supernatural
events subsection
female dude you're gonna find so many
like real ghosts caught on camera video
very creepy
you don't want to see that corner of the
internet cyborg you're just gonna be on
slapped ham all night
per tune sand worms
[Music]
that's where I left his change sure
flip it drop this in the sand a few
years ago tonight
mandatory
foot
Weird Al
it just leaves on the back seat just
propped up
CW era
anguish oh come on hold hands also like
this hip teenager music yes the kids
listen to yeah pop punk
Machine Gun Kelly brought it back
what
ah
[Applause]
goes right to your thighs Damien so much
cotton candy bro
[Laughter]
that's gotta be enough for a big ass
prize he's gotta give it to her
oh
it's it's sting oh Bilbo's sword
oh that's precious she only had four
tickets and she gave him the little 300
tickets sword Damien without altruism
months
that tastes like pure sugar boy were you
up in those mountains a long time
yeah I bet he'd hate candy you may be
insufferable but in your heart you are a
Kind and Generous soul
why did you say those Concepts
we must dance dance our hearts out
they're like taking time for World
building in this one yeah like character
development's happening and like not a
fight please
there's no autographs I'm a busy man nah
Damian's gonna Step Up
dance
okay I know how to Revolution and then
he starts an actual Revolution based off
his dancing using those symbols yeah
hope you're a good loser
we've seen he's not nope over and over
you gotta know you witnessed that he's
gonna murder you
hand foot coordination Damian's a
different job
quick study
are those Shazam lightning bolts now
they are yeah look at them go
hmm
oh no happiness not now they're waiting
for you
buy Zola 2000 spare chain Watson
bothering you
go chase her into The Amalgamated
Universe ah not the move on the hill
beyond the tent
[Music]
you're part of a team Raven they're
right behind you remember your training
this whole exercise is about
him it's a trick it is me child
oh oh no it's our destiny to be together
Raven always
ooh you're an Abomination girl
Abomination Marvel
so many crossovers
no glory
Trigon
[Music]
oh
mother of Azeroth give me strength
ooh we will last long enough
Teen Titans part of a team yeah see
these guys work as a team they're over
there dancing
no
oh no not the rail what if I'm a cow
years of training as a ninja has
prepared as cardio for this very battle
awesome dude
yes quite impressive
whatever
seems important to check in on
[Music]
Titans Go yeah there's like an anime
sometimes the animation team just make
some choices
oh yes hey I I want to feel this good
getting in any outfit yeah
if only clothes could do such things
stylistic one yeah
Damien just not in that Montage I know I
guess it's not a Titan he just puffed
his turtleneck collar up and he's ready
to go the Demonic emissaries my father
said your father
Steve Jobs powers activate I always
gotta get the sword
oh
come on Damien
that's right no
[Music]
no
yeah please tell me they're Undead
yes he's been working on the murders my
dad's gonna be pissed
oh dude Damon could probably let off so
much steam with these guys it's just
like the training Danger Room yeah
so do they possess the whole Justice
League thing is that why they're about
to versus I guess maybe yeah it's a good
call I just thought of the title of the
movie
and our only hope is these kids yeah
Titans Go these teens
I like the little Jitter effect too it's
good sound design too
yes yes sometimes you gotta go kangaroo
[Music]
oh I respect it is gonna remember that
in the morning
[Music]
Robin said I didn't know enough about
you
oh what I said is that he's gone that's
not the same as dead he's dead to me why
is he trying to kill you he's not trying
to kill me it's much worse
trying to give me a hug forever never
let me go I guess it starts with my mom
they decided to do the classic bride of
Satan right and guess who got to be the
lucky bride I doubt anyone expected it
to work
with ancient ceremony turned out to be
the real thing
hey when that happens hey everyone's
like oh I couldn't plan for this I
tried this before
wow
I'll text
didn't hesitate to hook up with the guy
who emerged from the smoke
I mean this is a Vibe I gotta say I like
I like this Christopher Lambert just
swings in four eyes
we need more DC romance novels so your
mom did it with Satan
I must have inherited my mom's terrible
judgment because I thought if I found
out more about the monster who made me
I'd be able to make sense of myself it's
not a bad call
all right
that is home
wow
oh no oh
Buzz for Cusco couscous poison
before he could use me I was able to
trap him inside a crystal
why didn't you go back to Azeroth this
is Azeroth
[Music]
that is a that is a beautiful painting
though as my new yeah
their storyline's great I mean I did not
expect it to be cool but this is this is
really cool you have no idea what he's
like Damien you've never met a monster
like Trigon you beat him once
my dad's a demon if we can't save one of
our own who can we save I thought you
hated us
I'm not wishing you dead anymore Robin's
right progress that's how Robin says I
love you I don't wear stuff on you
anymore her father's an interdimensional
demon
we can protect her
he knows they're here he wants them here
who if they stay everything will be lost
this is is our job father you have to
leave father
too late they're here
yes out from the Shadows
oh getting symbiated
go
it's a nerve toxic for pain
oh the captainian has Unearthed The
Infernal Shrine raided the hood to the
what
that's me you are the shrine's final
piece
yeah challenge us
[Music]
cool Power
it's like anamorphous yeah
[Music]
Andy brought his suit today it's Sprite
I mean naked in front of everyone
jeez never pair up with your similar you
have to change villains yeah it's like
fighting Pokemon yeah you always go with
different type beatle
oh
that looks so painful
I stopped my hand for an instant and
this one dies too I'll go has the
daughter of your lord Trigon I order you
to release these feeble humans oh boy I
hope nobody else is in the Teen Titans
building yeah they don't have employees
right
oh good they saved one get him inside do
you think when the youngest of them
turns 18 they have to remodel the T into
an a
[Laughter]
or like a g like for grown-ups Titans
adult title adult Titans Go on a
pedestal
Stargate
a deadish girl
we were meant to be together
it's really cool the way they realize
the Magic in this movie yeah a little
Tech feel yeah and like the yeah the
circles and the sort of like symmetry of
it all this one's made me so much more
excited for a Teen Titans movie sure
like this is so cool oh cool oh
she's in the Middle East 60 miles north
of Canada City Canada I put a tracer on
her when about 30 seconds after we met
in time I put one on each of you
what you guys barely held your own
against Flash and Wonder Woman and
that's without Superman being on Deck he
shouldn't be a problem
[Music]
got a way to take out super weird versus
Superman uh let me hear for it let's do
it so like the only time he's not
grimacing is when he's smiling like I
love The Duality of David yeah
cool use of Animation too with like
static to add like texture to certain
stuff yeah totally
Titans Go do they always say that a lot
okay it's great
they walk that cheesy line beautifully I
love Teen Titans
[Music]
you gotta go right for the big gun first
he gonna remember that
'd be great there it is remember that
yeah oh
his Instinct was to Stave him even as he
was dying
you mind removing that
facility
cool
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
yes it was really smart how they broke
up the team so like it's not Teen Titans
fighting Wonder Woman because that's
ridiculous like using Superman like this
she doesn't belong to you devil
oh Superman lasso of Truth yeah
let me go you alien pill
it's time for some uncomfortable truths
gotta ask question soups who are you
lasso commands you answer
I am Diana of the mascara
nicely done
it's okay
I've got you now just like in the movies
now let's both put our glasses on who
are we
you can get off my back now boy phony
ass
squads Damien come on now
nothing is right oh
Justice League and Teen Titans versus
demons yeah Trigon special
[Music]
Tim Curry and Legend action that's right
it's a big boy
about a big boom Raven has a plan
Titans need my help
oh I'm going to hell
yes yes
do this
I'm going to hell so metal the crystal
can only be touched by me he may have
escaped it but he can't destroy it I
just hope you left a trail of
breadcrumbs of death blood crumbs skull
maggots over here yeah
no
I think it likes that yeah
the sudden urge to play Doom
[Music]
not great
what the hell
is he possessed is it because he's in
hell is it the animals there yeah does
he have access to new hell animals I
think that would make some sense that's
what I demand for my Comics continuity
Comics are known for him plausibility
[Music]
yeah demon Beast Boy
gar you still with us
Shaka you might not be able to talk but
he can still be a teenager yeah
[Music]
come on up his butt like Thanos take him
out right
then tickled
you sneeze on him no yeah yeah that's
that's not great you're still flashed
though all right now we go up his butt
yeah Plan B Plan B for butt
I know
I know I I have to do it I'm Superman
this is a problem
[Music]
Goblin Beast Boy
was made of like flesh and teeth yeah
it's gross
too much
it's a lot of tumors there's a lot of
tumors Hydra tubers
who is your daddy and what does it do oh
tie the heads together or something
get it Raven
mine work on those oh
thank you
[Music]
damn Damian my blood it's a trick I saw
you die
no trick you're in Hell bro he can give
us the world we wanted you and I she's
the only one who stands in the way prove
your love grandson take care of this for
me of course of course
are you afraid to do the one act that
will restore Me to Life have you
forgotten your heritage you are an Al
Gore I'm a Titan yeah
yeah buddy do anything for love but I
won't do that
you think your allies can stop me now
that I'm here
oh no he's out there attack on
tightening yeah seriously attack on Teen
Titans my only weakness was loving you
but all you were capable of giving was
pain friends who give me love and the
strength to do this no reconnect raccoon
now you've got a smaller house yes if
you do this one more time it's gonna be
even smaller frankly studio apartment
New York closet
[Music]
nah dude there it is
oh is that is that weakness oh
oh yeah
[Music]
sustenance turn the demon Trigon within
the sacred shot now forever
so the first time did she just say now
and like for a while now and for a bit
we might got to talk father daughter
stuff give a chance to cool down maybe
he'll think it over
[Music]
here he comes
sweet ravened
careful collateral damage it's best to
have to plan it you know whoa that's
cool
that's how you take out a demon king
[Music]
living space
dude thanks for helping out it was nice
to have a big gun around it was nice not
to be the kid for once when you've been
in the majors you know what I'm saying
ouch but fair oh Jesus
ugh great work Titans your determination
and teamwork saved the world
and US
hey guys it's Pete tonight
less than 30.
carry on Titans
yes yes okay that was awesome yes the
man of two teams
I love it I love it
Uncle cyborg is here so good isn't that
he always said we should be together
there's got to be torture for him well
you can take the girl out of hell
stuff crushed respect absolutely
[Music]
jeez dude yeah look at that I wonder
what that's like to have a yammering
away in your head all day Sam that was
great Sam Leo but I like you Sammy he's
the guy from the last one yeah that's
right fake to sound you Sam Liu Sam not
simulio holy man that was incredible uh
a favorite
whoa
they deserve a party Teen Titans party
all those fish they killed
oh oh oh what
hello that was
star who is who is coming uh
Rosario Dawson's back that's right just
to Marvel's a great Batman again
I thought that was his voice
I should have called it out awesome yeah
it was time to figure it out it's a very
specific his voice as soon as I hear it
now oh that's awesome well because it's
like yeah because they like filtered it
and then yeah but like jump around those
Cadence is specific I was like now that
I know it yeah it's total sense oh
that's awesome I wish I threw that out
there yeah
ah
well dude dude I love this one like
this was everything you want out of two
teams in a movie it like that it had
actual character development like we we
had said that was one of our issues with
some of the other ones this was the
opposite they let us breathe with these
characters and the characterizations in
this elseworld V thing felt like a good
blend of
the comet counterpart and the thing they
built like I didn't dislike Diana or
Superman no like they worked for me uh I
I love this is definitely top three for
me
okay yeah no I would say it's definitely
definitely a a see now now we're getting
into that territory where it's like oh
sh is
Arkham's incredible this one those those
jump out Flashpoint Flash turtles
turtles okay top five it's top five top
five yeah man this is gonna be hard to
rank now that like this many are this
good yeah it's gonna be real hard to
rank yeah well and I love the way that
this used like I feel like we do the
kind of biggest dive on Raven and and we
get the sort of biggest development on
her but I love that they use that as a
means of
not solely for that purpose but like as
a byproduct you know that helps Damien
like this yeah instrumental factor in
helping Damien along because he's kind
of our eye line in this whole journey
like David's been the most consistent I
think yeah and like a lot of the time
you know we're kind of at odds with
Damien I feel like yeah so uh yeah it's
neat to have him be in that position
where he's still Damien he's still very
much you know got his attitude but like
it works and like we're pretty endeared
to him at this point like I really like
him now yeah
oh
and so and so yeah like as an eye line
uh yeah I think it makes it's good
because you can still keep growing but
at the same time yeah he is sort of your
Cipher into all these things that are
happening and like I feel like the
stories they're telling are getting
bigger in a way that like only animation
can do like that would be impossible I
think live action like the cast The
Demon stuff like you'd have so much
story to tell like maybe it's like a
fifth or sixth movie but you'd have to
have both teams a tablet established
separately and then so I love that like
animation can do stories like this in
one because we've only like really met
Damien like of the Titans like obviously
we know the Justice League but they
weren't the lead to this no and I
thought they they did a really nice job
of having them feel present and feel
necessary to the overall picture but
leaving this to the Titans as the ones
who really have to solve and get into
the nitty-gritty of what's going on here
and as I noticed like Midway through the
way they like took out Certain Justice
League members and kept certain other
ones and like the genius of not having
them like fight one Roman because that
wouldn't work with power set because
then you'd undermine Wonder Woman's
power or you'd overplay the Titans like
it's important that they feel
differently power scaled and a lot of
times power scales are the first things
to go in any of these fights sure comic
book movie it's TV show like power scale
is really hard to determine who's like
gonna win they did a really good job
efficiently moving those chess pieces so
it felt practical yeah absolutely and
and just the displacement of events it's
like you know when you have certain uh
iterations of the Justice League doing
their thing it's like they're kind of
here to protect Earth while we get to
the bottom of this in the other Realms
and stuff like that and I love that we
had time to do bonding I love that we
had time to actually have like like this
felt like a natural story that grew into
something else like yeah you've got
Damien working with the Justice League
and then he you know takes this sort of
rash uh course of action that you know
kind of even Sparks a minor debate
within the league you know Superman's
like yeah good job I mean you really
gotta listen to your dad man and then
border school instead of going back to
monk Hood which he's already done yeah
now he's got to go somewhere else so I
like that they tried to solve it through
like your past is this that didn't work
now we got to try the superhero approach
that does work to a point where you're
learning new lessons and then tying it
to Dick Grayson who's often a Teen
Titans member or leader that really was
cool because he's been consistently a
mentor Big Brother type so like the it's
the long game Arc with all these
characters Batman not knowing how to
handle it Nightwing trying to help the
different versions of Damien's history
and then tying all of that like you said
to the grandfather with the demon
parallel with her story and that endears
us to the new Teen Titans characters we
just met like it does so much World
building yeah impressively yeah quickly
yeah makes us like Diana and Superman's
relationship more which is not something
I usually dig like I don't think then I
don't ship them but with this elseworld
I like them now like they they got me
now yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like I I
you know not to slight Lois Lane but
here when they had those little romantic
beats between Wonder Woman and Superman
it just felt kind of natural to how
they've drawn this University yeah yeah
I agree and it seems like conscientious
to yeah the the just the way that they
carry and portray the characters so far
here and it works like they mentioned
Steve Trevor at one point so if the
world feels bigger I like that they
mentioned a character we'd met in this
case you know James Cameron um like we
get we get those little moments of
connectivity without having to like
waste screen time and like this for an
hour and 20 did so much and still gave
us time like at the carnival like I love
how much time they took to endear us to
these characters instead of like oh look
you like them they're teens like they
they let us live with them well and also
feeling like uh I feel like sometimes
you can introduce a group or or you know
additional characters then it'll feel
like where were these guys all the other
movies whereas here it didn't I didn't
have that feeling it didn't feel like
some kind of weird contrivance had to
exist so that now is the time that we're
finally meeting like yeah it made sense
to finally bring that into the story and
then meet these new characters through
that and see what progress they're
making because now especially with the
more direct involvement of the Justice
League Damien's there you could see how
they might factor in in a grander sense
as you know this universe this Animated
Universe expands out and yeah I don't
think we have to see them every time I'm
excited to see them again like I think
that it's going to be fun to like kind
of weave into the tapestry yeah exactly
and I liked uh just the I mean Teen
Titans tower does feel like they are the
only five people in it oh yeah oddly
that big old T is just those folks just
hanging out it's just Blue Beetle uh
what Beast Boy Raven and what's her name
what's the Starfire Starfire and Damien
now that's it Damian's new and he gets a
lot of wings because he's frankly the
whole half the team sure I love though
that they feel like they could have just
been training the whole time like you
said and not involved but now that we've
met them like we get small street level
missions and then make Cosmic missions
like what Marvel had been doing phase
one through three yeah and I think Teen
Titans are going to be really important
to what James Gunn builds because of
that like I think having a a more
contained team and then a big Global
team is going to be really like great
live action yeah and and this was
interesting too because I I like this is
I don't have as many I don't have many
experiences with Teen Titans material
sure and you know comic books in general
there are often debates about like you
know who who are these ideally aimed at
and I feel like Teen Titans is an
interesting Prospect because I think it
was I was watching this and it hit me it
struck me that this kind of aims more
directly at I would say teens yeah in in
us in a way that like
I feel like a lot of comic book stuff
either skews
Kitty or adult oh 100 and this was like
no this is like four like you know the
the they're making like little semi lewd
little jokes and stuff like that and
like they're talking about stuff that
teens might talk about and it's not like
overly edgy but at the same time it's
not like they're the child Titans right
right right so it's like you have this
like weird little Interline and granted
it involves more of the adult characters
but you know it's like Nightwings on
this uh this video call with Starfire
and like there's just this weird kind of
like sexual tension 100 that I don't
necessarily associate with that that
other sort of semi-binary that these can
fall into so like yeah there's like a
unique sort of like additional maturity
even though it's not as full on mature
it's additional immaturity yeah exactly
it's like both that Wing's got his like
he's a Casanova like that's established
but the use of how they had like the
camera and stuff is very like yeah like
and I think you're right like you you
still have the adult night wing and you
still have these teens but the choice of
certain things allows for that audience
to go like ah yeah yeah and you got
Beast Boy like you know with his like
it's a classic gag of like oh he
transformed no he's naked but then he's
like but I sleep naked and I'm just like
this this is like kind of weird but also
Like This lends itself to the team to
the market of it and I I think you'd
like a lot of the Teen Titans books like
right now I feel like I would yeah Cami
Garcia's writing and she uh wrote like
young adult novels she wrote like
Beautiful Creatures which got adapted
like she's usually a young adult novel
writes
Beautiful Creatures it's so not bad I
liked it so she wrote that and now she's
at DC uh writing uh basically it's a
book series of graphic novels so each
one of them is a whole story worry and
they're not out monthly they're
literally like every six months or so
they put out one and they're like one's
Raven one's Beast Boy and then every so
often there's a team up and they're
really cool because they're illustrated
by this guy Gabriel Piccolo this
Brazilian artist that's fantastic and he
does these really
um it's almost anime inspired but
American cartoonist style art but then
the colorist only uses like green is the
predominant color in Beast Boy and
purple is a prominent color so there's
all the colors but like it's focusing on
those colors and the new one just came
out for I forget which character but
they're on like book only on book four
they're not that far into it and like
I've been interviewing her about these
books since like 2019 like this has been
a four year run for me with this piece
and like I love these characters because
I got to learn them the new modern take
through them but then George Perez one
of my favorite creators really made the
Teen Titans like he's the guy that
reinvented Wonder Woman um and brought
her to like the mainstream and then he
went on to do Teen Titans and like
they're the team at DC for me maybe even
more than Justice League because it
always feels like Batman and friends or
Superman and friends like they feel like
a team yeah as opposed to like these big
heroes United yeah like they feel like a
team and George Perez like was integral
to making that happen and uh I got to do
his his farewell tour uh before he
retired and then he has since passed
away unfortunately but like we got to
like travel together and like do a bunch
of like uh cons of like what the fans
mean to him and he's one of the most
intimately connected to every one of his
fans like he remembers cosplayers he
like you know takes great pride and like
I invented Raven and that's one of the
most cosplayed characters I want to talk
to every Raven cosplayer and find out
why they connect like George would
literally want to know what that
character meant to them and not even
like narcissistically because he read it
but like because he wanted to connect to
the person through his connection to the
character like George was such an
incredible man so uh Teen Titans have
become more and more important to me
because of George because of Cami
because of like what they are to Comic
culture and I think that's a really
unique space because they're newish
they're like 30 years old 20 years old
yeah and it's fascinating too like I
love that I love hearing that because in
a way I feel especially like about you
know taking that time to be like why do
you why does this character of Raven
especially resonate so much with you and
and I feel like
there's something about the again the
target audience the aim the the the
characters that largely Encompass this
kind of story that I feel like has like
a a more direct potential to like impact
a reader or a viewer or something like
that in a way that like anything you
read impacts you and I'm sure that you
know like kids learn from Reading you
know Comics or whatever but I I don't
know there's just some kind of like
specific yeah there's a Vitality of the
potential for connection there that I
think is like really special and lovely
and and so they're not hiding the
teenness it's in the it's the first word
like there's nothing to that yeah and
the whole point probably is is that
along the way they're going through
growing pains and discovering life as
well as all this super stuff yeah and uh
and yeah like I love the way that that
parallels here into the fantasy because
yeah like they're dealing with demons
and they got you know problems with
their parents obviously and she is and
yeah and she and Damien can kind of
understand each other based off that but
then this also branches out into like
full on hell like that's that's the
other cool thing is I really like
obviously like the Sci-Fi the crime the
detective stuff that permeates a lot of
these movies but this one was like
especially like demon fantasy heavy
metal you know hellish I mean look at
now like Teen Titans Judas contract
justice league dark like I'm really
excited to see where things go like I
don't know what's next but like it's
really fun that we have opened that door
you're right like we've everything so
big there's a lot of potential now and
this was 2016. so I don't know when this
ends if it's ended but we've still got
like however many years like now we've
got seven years worth of animated yeah
man and a new one just came out like
this year apparently I don't know if
it's in this universe but a new DC
animated like people are raving about in
2023 fudge yeah so like we got tons uh
but yeah we've talked about this one a
bit longer than we usually do but
hopefully you enjoyed because yeah this
one's in my top three to five there's so
many guys and I love Uncle cyborg at the
end dude yeah like a 19 to 20 year old
cyborg being a little too old to be a
Teen Titan but a little too young to be
a Justice League member is so perfect I
love it like it's so good that college
Adrian like what am I yeah yeah I like
pizzas still though yeah you know and
I'm still committed to my Justice League
obligations but I I wanna I wanna be a
cool yeah the cool guy the big guy bring
pizza everybody likes me it's like a
cyborg man I'm not big I'm not big
brother but I'm not little brother yeah
I love that for cyborg like it's so good
but yeah I got a lot out of this one I
always love doing these with John so
please leave a comment below let us know
dude these are blessed every time a lot
of times always look forward to these uh
so yeah if you want to want us to keep
making them because we want to keep
making them share this like this all the
things this you know what to do hit that
notification Bell and let us know which
of these is your favorite and if you
liked Justice League versus Teen Titans
and challenge so the big two for me or
George Perez's run on Titans and Kami
Garcia and Gabriel Piccolo's run on
Titans in the comments if you've read
Teen Titans recommend me and John some
Teen Titans stuff we're gonna get him
some Comics so all right dive in much
loved reject Nation we'll see you next
time for whatever next happens we we
don't know first time watch that's the
point all right we'll see you soon but
before we go we gotta give a special
super sexy shout out tomorrow
Mark Leach because your name is cool
it's got strong consonants it's got
Great Vowel use it's concise I can see
it being rhymed well as also with its
impact of both Mark and leech being
single syllable one two punches just big
fan of the name I just saw it I was like
hey it's cool I like it I can vouch for
that Mark who who is it I know exactly
who it is just got it hotspot yeah oh
it's a good word
a little extra like the H is pronounced
in this hotspot yeah
Mark Leach I hope you have a wonderful
day I know leeches get a bad rap but
they're also used medicinally sure and
sometimes they save lives and in the
greater ecosystem of Life all animals
are important so even if you don't
particularly like leeches know that it's
vital to the swamp ecosystem which is
vital to the ecosystem around it which
then spreads to all life on Earth so
leeches are vital and you are vital art
Leach